We've been talking about the
expansion of the universe. Uh, and,
uh, in answer, I want to
follow up on something I said,
kind of an answer to a question last time,
which is,
uh,
that it turns out that the expansion of
the universe alone doesn't require you
to have a big bang.
There's other explanations or in
particular one other class of explanation,
uh, which is compatible with the
observation of the expanding universe,
but doesn't exactly,
uh,
lead to a big bang in the sense
that we think of it today.
And so I want to talk about these
alternatives. Uh, this is, uh,
frontiers and controversies as of 1950,
uh,
in 1920,
you'll recall they were worried about
whether the spiral nebulae where island
galaxies of their own or not,
that was settled by hobbles
observation in the 1950s. Uh,
it had become clear that it really is
true that the universe is expanding. Uh,
but there were two categories of
explanation that were being put forward,
uh, to explain that and, uh, deciding
which is, which was the current,
a big topic of the day. So,
uh, the universe expand.
And what do we make of this
fact? Well, one option is, uh,
the big bang,
what we now call the Big Bang,
which as I've mentioned,
implies that in the past everything
was closer together, was denser.
Uh, and that creates other
changes. If things get denser,
they also get hotter.
And you may remember from chemistry.
So this implies in the past,
uh,
things were different from how
they are now. They were denser,
hotter,
uh,
uh, and, uh, that in the future, uh,
it'll go the other way.
Uh,
things will become sparser and cooler.
Uh, and there may be other
changes associated with this. Uh,
there may be different kinds of galaxies
in the past from now and then and
different kinds of galaxies now as
compared to the future and so forth.
If the universe,
uh,
is a place whose bulk
properties can change in time.
So things change,
uh,
in time.
And the implication is that you can
extrapolate this back to an initial
singularity, that there was a moment
at some point in the past where,
uh, all a currently existing space
was piled up in a single point.
This is the way I talked about this
last time was that the scale factor was
equal to zero.
And so there is this implication of,
uh,
an initial singularity.
Now this is not the initial singularity
is not the kind of thing that can be
verified scientifically because all the
physical laws break down the same way
they do in the singularity,
inside a black hole or at an event
horizon or something like that. Uh,
but nevertheless,
that's the implication.
That's the extrapolation
of this set of ideas.
But, uh, at least at the time,
that was not the only set of ideas
that could explain this expansion.
There was an alternative which
was described as the steady state.
I should say that both of these names
were given to these ideas by people who
supported the steady state.
Uh, Big Bang, uh, was, uh, uh,
that phrase was used as an insult by
this steady state people to make fun of,
uh, the ideas of the big bang, which
we now actually know to be correct.
And that's why that particular
phrase, uh, is in a way so misleading,
uh, that they were deliberately
trying to a obscure and, uh, uh,
insult some of the ideas in the
big bang from time to time. Uh,
astronomical organizations in popular
magazines run contests to rename the great
theory and come up with some better name
that won't give you in your mind the
impression of an explosion coming out
from some central point. Uh, and, uh,
people send in suggestions and
it never gets anywhere. Uh,
we're stuck with the big bang.
Uh,
but it is good to remember that it was
named by its opponents who supported this
steady state. So how would
this work? Uh, the idea,
the central idea here is that new,
uh,
the university sticks expands,
but then new matter and energy is created,
uh, to, uh, fill in the void,
the void as the universe expands. So sure,
all galaxies are moving away from us,
but new galaxies are being created
where the old galaxies used to be.
And the consequences of that is
that the past and the future both,
uh, have a similar bulk
characteristics. The density,
the overall density is the
same. Uh, and other, uh,
characteristics are the same
because as things move further away,
you simply replace them with other
things like them. And so, uh, you know,
you have to kind of invent a sub
way of creating matter and energy,
uh, but that's not nearly as bad
as creating a whole universe,
which is what you have to do, uh, in the
case of the, uh, uh, of the big banks.
So, uh, in this case, the past
and the future are the same. The,
it also implies that the universe is
eternal in contrast to the big bang where
there's this initial moment, which
a one then instantly asks, well,
how did that happen and
what happened before it?
So we get around that this is
an eternal process. Uh, and, uh,
it's also infinite.
And so we don't have to start asking
these awkward questions about what's
outside the universe. And
so people found this, uh,
in some ways much more satisfying.
Uh,
and so there were these two
quite different explanations
of the observed fact
that the universe was expanding. Now,
the historians of science who, uh,
have studied this controversy,
some of them make the claim that which
side you ended up on in the 1950s before
there was a lot of evidence either way,
this was kind of a philosophical rather
than a scientific question at the time.
Uh, that which side you ended up
here, uh, dependent largely on,
uh,
your religious beliefs or lack thereof.
And they document this and a lot of the
work on the Big Bang and a lot of the
supporters of the Big Bang, uh,
we're, as I mentioned last time, uh,
Catholics in one important
case that this guy,
the metro who worked out
all the equations, wasn't in
fact a Catholic priest, uh,
also a physicist in his
spare time. Uh, and, uh,
this is a nice, uh, kind of idea
because from that point of view,
because it gives you this initial
moment of creation, uh, which is,
uh,
if you're a religious person and it's
relatively easy to come up with a reason
why that might've happened. Uh, on the
other hand, a lot of the scientists,
particularly in Britain where the
steady state was, uh, largely developed,
we're of a kind of atheistic or agnostic
turn of mine and they didn't like this
initial singularity.
And they liked the idea of an eternal,
infinite universe as actually
Einstein did too. Uh, because, uh,
uh,
you didn't have to have a creation event
and you didn't have to invoke the kinds
of ideas that come along
with that. Uh, and, uh,
uh, there's some dispute over over
how much this really matter to people.
But what was clear is in the 1950s,
this was not a question for which there
was scientific evidence either way.
And so what the scientific evidence
said was that the universe expanded.
And then you could follow either of
these Arabs. Interestingly, however, uh,
these two hypotheses make
quite different predictions,
which in the end turned out to
be testable. And in particular,
um,
what it,
what it predicted if
the big bank predicts a,
it makes this very strong prediction
that the past is fundamentally different
looking,
uh, from the present. Now,
uh, it, over the course
of a human lifetime,
this isn't going to make
a lot of difference. Uh,
the galaxies don't get that
much further away from us, uh,
in 20 or 30 years, but it, uh,
but one can actually look into the past
by looking at things that are far away.
This is because the speed of light
is finite. When we look at the sun,
we don't see the sun as it is right now.
We see the sun as it was eight minutes
ago when the light started to travel
toward us because the sun is eight
light minutes. It's minutes away.
If we look at Alpha Centaury the
nearest star other than the sun, uh,
if Alpha Centaury, uh, blew up or
disappeared or something right now,
we wouldn't know about it for four years
because it's four light years away. Uh,
similarly, if we look at, uh, uh, uh,
a galaxy that's 10 mega parsecs away,
a mega parse,
a parsec is three light years.
So a mega parsec is 3 million light years.
Uh, some galaxy that's
10, uh, that's 10 light,
10 makeup parsecs away.
That's 30 million light years away.
So we're seeing it not as it is, but
as it was 30 million years ago. Now,
it turns out that in the, in the course
of cosmic time, a few million years here,
here, here, here or there, it doesn't
make any difference to anybody. Uh,
but once you get into billions,
now you're talking cosmic time.
Uh, and so if you look at things that
are billions of light years away,
that turns out to be a
substantial fraction of the
age of the universe predicted
by the big bang.
We'll get back a little later in this
lecture to how you determine what the age
of the universe is supposed to be.
But if you go back a substantial
fraction of the age of the universe,
if you look back, uh, that,
uh, over distances that great,
then you predict that you ought to see
things that look different from the
galaxies you see today.
Because the universe at that time was
denser and hotter and the galaxies were
younger on average. And Andrew ought to
be able to see some kinds of differences.
So the passage different from the present,
and this is observable,
uh,
through,
this concept of the lookback time,
uh,
just the fact that the
further away something is the
longer it's taken the light
to travel to you. And so you're actually
seeing things not as they are right now,
but as they are in the past.
And so you can imagine a great research
project where you sort of look at nearby
galaxies to see how things are in the
current day. Then you look at really,
really distant ones, some substantial
fraction of the age of the universe ago.
And you ask yourself the question,
are those galaxies the same as
the galaxies that exist today?
Or are they in some sense different?
Uh, so that's a testable prediction.
There's also a testable
prediction on this side,
which is the two ought to actually be
able to find these places where the new
matter and energy is being created
because that's a constant ongoing process.
It has to be cause it's got to fill
in the empty spaces left behind by the
expanded galaxies. So the prediction
over here that is that there exists,
uh,
places of matter
and energy creation.
So this is potentially testable.
And in the 1960s,
evidence was actually found that
kind of decided this question when,
which is why we now no longer
believe in this steady state.
And two things happened. Actually. There
were a number of things that happen. Uh,
but one of them was the discovery
of what were called quasars.
Uh,
these are now known to be a accreting
supermassive black holes,
but they didn't know that then.
So this is in the 1960s.
That's what we think they are now.
But the way it did,
no it then all they knew is that
they had discovered, uh, uh,
a great source of huge amounts of energy
and you'd think that this would
be a very good thing. Uh, uh,
some kind of unknown energy source would
be just the thing for the steady state
people because that's what they needed.
They needed this some kind of source of
mass energy creation and indeed that was
claimed for a little
while. These things. Uh,
the main characteristic of these things
is that they have very high red shifts,
which implies very large distances.
Uh, because uh, uh, velocity is
proportional to the distance.
That's the Hubble law. Everybody
agreed that the Hubble lovers, right?
So these things were known to
be large distances away. Uh,
and so if you're a steady state
person, you say, well, that's great.
If they're so far away,
they must be incredibly bright.
Otherwise we wouldn't be able to see them.
And that there's our,
there's our energy source that we
require a, if you're a big bank person,
what you say is,
ah,
now we finally found a bunch of things
that are really far away and we can ask
the question,
are things that are that far away the
same as in the local universe or are they
different? And what it turned out, uh,
one of the very first things that was
discovered is that there were many more,
uh,
quasars in the past.
Then there are now,
uh,
and so whatever they are
super massive black holes are,
or whatever hypothesis
you have for these things,
it turns out they're dining out.
There were more of them in the past,
then there are now they were brighter.
Uh,
and so here is an example of a significant
change in the composition of the
universe.
Yeah.
Uh, which is the thing that's
predicted by the big bang. And so, uh,
uh,
although initially it looked like quasars
might be helpful to the steady state
as soon as they started
to get enough of them.
So you could do these
kinds of statistical tests.
It became the first really strong
evidence that the universe was changing in
time. This was not the only thing
that was discovered in the 1960s.
Another thing is the so called
cosmic microwave background.
And we'll talk much more about
that, uh, later on right now.
Uh,
I just want to say that what this is,
is it's a radiation that was created,
uh, that was generated
when the universe was, uh,
when,
uh,
the universe was much
denser than it is now,
a much hotter than it is now. In fact, uh,
it comes from it's radiation
emitted by ionized hydrogen.
So this is when the whole universe
was at 10,000 degrees or so Kelvin,
uh,
obviously much hotter than
the universities right now
and much smoother all this
hydrogen rather than being locked
up in individual stars and stars,
a concentrated in individual galaxies,
all this hydrogen was very smoothly
distributed around space. Uh,
and, uh, so this came from a time,
this radiation, which you can,
which you can easily detect it with
radio telescopes and the like, uh,
comes from a time when the
universe was much denser,
hotter and smoother than it is
today. Again, in accordance with, uh,
uh, uh, with the prediction
of the big banks. So this is,
this provided very strong
support for the big bag.
And, uh, the discoverers
of this, uh, have got,
there've been Nobel prizes given
out on a regular basis for, uh, uh,
discoveries related to the cosmic
microwave background. And as I say,
we'll come back, I'll, I'll, I'll talk
about that at some length later on. Uh,
another thing that was discovered is
that the universe is pretty clearly,
uh, mostly three quarters,
hydrogen and one quarter helium,
just about every cosmic object you see.
Not the earth,
but the solar system as
a whole has that, uh, uh,
has those proportions and all stars
have these proportions and all galaxies
consist of stars that
have these proportions.
And it turns out this could be
explained by the Big Bang, uh,
when it was a denser,
hotter and smoother, uh,
uh,
in the early universe.
Yeah,
it was hot enough for hydrogen fusion,
hydrogen fusion into helium,
but it didn't last very long because
the universe was expanding and cooling.
And you need to have very
high temperatures in order
to have hydrogen fusion.
That's why it can only happen in the
center of the sun or in an atomic bomb
explosion or something
like that. Uh, and so, uh,
the universe for about three minutes
was hot enough for hydrogen to fuse.
And if you ask yourself what fraction of
the hydrogen feuds during the time the
universe, uh, was hot
enough for that to occur,
the answer turns out to be about a
quarter of it in exact agreement with the
currently observed fractions of
hydrogen and helium in the universe.
So this is, uh, in first three minutes,
there's a famous popular book from the
1980 [inaudible] called the first three
minutes, which discusses this by Steven
Weinberg, uh, in the first three minutes,
one quarter of hydrogen,
uh,
fuses into helium.
And afterwards,
no more.
Yeah.
Because it's too cool.
For these reactions to occur. So that
was another piece of evidence that,
uh, the, the, uh, the big bang was
the right explanation and the, uh,
uh, uh, steady state
was not yes. Question.
Sorry.
Uh, so, uh, if you start from time
zero when everything is put together,
after three minutes,
the universe has cooled sufficiently
so that you can't have hydrogen fusion
generally then nothing, no more
nuclear reactions occur until much,
much later when stars form.
And we know how fast the universe
is expanding because we, uh,
we can measure the Hubble
constant now, uh, and so you know,
how long it takes for the
universe to expand, uh,
to the point where the temperature
drops enough so that there's no general
hydrogen fusion anymore.
And then you do this little calculation
of how much fuses during that time.
Other questions?
Okay.
Um,
hmm.
More recently with the Hubble Space
Telescope and other other big ground based
telescopes, uh, we've discovered, uh,
that you, you can now see galaxies
that are very far away that are, uh,
as they were a substantial
fraction of the, uh,
of the age of the university go.
Uh,
and by now it's clear that galaxies evolve
and that the statistical demographics
of galaxies, how many there are, how
massive they are, how big they are,
all those kinds of things that those
statistics changed dramatically over the
course of the universe over the course
of the amount of look back time that we
can, uh, that we can
currently observe. Uh,
so galaxies evolve, uh, uh,
very significantly.
So everything points,
uh,
toward the big bang and
away from the steady state.
Uh,
much to the surprise of a lot
of the scientists who felt,
uh, possibly correctly given
what was known in the 1950s,
the steady state was a
more elegant solution. Uh,
and so let's see, the fable here is, uh,
the demise of the steady state.
Okay.
Uh, and the moral, well, their
various morals to this. Uh,
but let me be provocative
and say, uh, that sometimes,
uh, science, uh,
is anti atheistic,
yes.
Stick,
not anti religious,
uh, because it could've come
out the other way, right? Uh,
it could have turned out that the steady
state was right and then you wouldn't
have had this, uh, uh, then
you wouldn't have had this, uh,
moment of creation, uh, and, uh, uh,
and you wouldn't, uh, and, and, uh,
Pope John Paul the second wouldn't have
been so enthusiastic about astrophysics
in just the same way that it might
have turned out that human beings are
fundamentally different from all
other species of animals. Uh,
and if that had been true,
uh,
the geneticist would have discovered
that instead of what they did discover.
And so, uh, there's a feeling,
particularly in current political debates
that is somehow intrinsically anti
religious. Uh, and I think that
isn't true. It's not, it, it, it,
it isn't one way or another, it's just a
way of finding stuff out. And sometimes,
as in this particular case,
uh, you might find out, uh,
that the atheist or whatever the
atheist had proposed a is wrong.
And that's actually what happened
in this particular case. Uh,
so the demise of the steady
state is, uh, uh, uh,
one of the big things that happened in
the latter half of the 20th century.
And so now, uh, the
scientific evidence is very,
very strongly in favor of the big
bang. Ah, I should define what I mean,
I think by the Big Bang
theory because as I said,
this is a phrase coined by its enemies.
Uh,
and it's one of these
phrases like black hole,
which actually doesn't have a
technical definition, uh, and, uh,
you get into trouble by people using
it in different ways. Uh, and so, uh,
if,
uh,
if what you mean by this is that
in the past the universe was denser
and hotter and smoother
cause it's, it's constantly, you
know, forming new stars and galaxies.
Everything is, is, is getting
more lumpy with time. Uh,
and that you can extrapolate this
to an initial singularity,
then I think,
uh,
then I think there's extremely strong
scientific evidence in favor of this.
But you have to keep your eye on this
word extrapolate because sometimes the big
is used,
uh,
is used to describe
this moment of initial,
uh, creation or whatever you want to
call it. There's this initial moment of,
uh, of infinite density
and somehow everything, uh,
starting to expand, there's a,
you can't observe that that's us.
That's one of these things that
you can't see uh, now or you know,
with our current theories at
any point in, uh, in the future.
And so that's an extrapolation.
That's not an observation
and that's a fundamental,
fundamentally different things.
So if you use big bang to
indicate that particular moment,
then you can say that the
scientific evidence for the actual,
that actual moment isn't, uh, uh,
isn't strong and indeed
couldn't even exist, uh,
within our current current
theories because there's
all the physics breaks down
there. Uh, and so what
you mean when, what,
what I mean when I say that there's a lot
of scientific support for the Big Bang,
is there support for this idea that
the universe is changing in time?
It was dense or hotter
and smoother in the past.
And then if you extrapolate this back,
there was an initial singularity some
number of years ago and you can actually
figure out how many years ago that was,
which is what I'm about to do. Net.
Uh, and so this, uh, is now the
kind of currently accepted theory,
I should say. Uh, there are a few remnant
hold outs from the steady state type,
uh, who, uh, uh, annoy the
rest of us by not giving in.
Uh, and, uh,
there's actually been some interesting
controversy over the years about, uh,
you know,
how much telescope time do you give to
people whose proposal is to look for the
places where mass has created
in the steady state theory, uh,
if nobody else believes that theory
anymore, uh, and, uh, uh, uh,
by now the answer is none. Uh, but it
took quite a while to get to that point.
Okay.
Do people lie about what they're
going to observe? Excellent.
That graduate students or amuse?
Uh, no. What happens is this,
you have to present,
so you have to write these proposals
because the telescopes are oversubscribed
and you have to come up with a
plausible thing that you're going to do.
Now it then it then varies how this,
how this is actually done. An operation
in the space telescope for example,
what you have to do is then you fill
out what's called a phase two form,
which tells exactly where the space
telescope is supposed to point and for how
long. And you submit that and
they upload it and they do it.
If you deviated drastically from the
target list you gave them when they
approved your proposal, that'll get
flagged and they won't do it. Uh,
on the other hand,
on ground based telescopes,
you kind of go to the telescope and still
in many cases you operate it yourself
and there's not a lot of control
over where you point the thing,
the control then happens later.
Uh,
one of the key components of a proposal
for telescope time is what you did with
the data you got from the last amount
of telescope time they gave you.
And you know,
you have to list all the publications
or if you haven't actually gotten around
to publishing anything, which is
usually the case with me recently. Uh,
you have to show a little,
little graphs, uh, or, you know,
describe the data and what you're going
to do with it and so forth. And, uh,
one of the things I,
I sit on these committees that make
these kinds of decisions and one of the
things you look for is if they haven't
done interesting work and kind of done
what they claimed they would
do the last time round, uh,
their proposal goes down to the bottom.
You're always looking for ways to
trash other people's proposals. Uh,
because you've got seven times more.
In the case of the space telescope,
you've got seven times more
proposals than you can grant,
of which only a small handful
are not worth doing a.
And so any opportunity you have to say,
you know, these guys are Bozos, uh,
you definitely take that opportunity
because otherwise you have way too many
good proposals leftover. So there's a
kind of internal control that isn't,
uh, explicit on this sort of
thing. And after a while, you know,
if people keep getting up in
public and saying, you know,
quasars are sources of mass energy
creation that and therefore support the,
the steady state, even if they're
a great big quasar expert, uh,
you start to get a little bit queasy
about giving them large amounts of
telescope time that might be a more
profitably be used by someone else.
This then gets interpreted by the, uh, uh,
remnant steady state
supporters or whoever the,
the minority idea might be of a hugely
o oppressive scientific bureaucracy,
you know, not allowing the
maverick wonderful thinker
to do their own thing. Uh,
and that sometimes is true,
uh,
but not often.
Most of the time it's the same people
not allowing the insane people to use the
telescopes. Uh, and that's
actually a much more common thing.
And so while it can be good propaganda
to say, yeah, these, uh, oppressive, uh,
elitist, uh, uh, you know, bureaucratic,
uh, uh, people mafia who
runs the scientific world,
or not allowing my great idea to have to
get any opportunities to prove itself,
uh, most of the time it turns out
the establishment is right. Uh,
and so, uh, you know,
there is this interesting question
about allocation of resources.
It's not just telescope time,
more importantly, even money. Uh,
there's a big debate right now,
for example,
in the theoretical physics
community about string theory.
String theory is the hot theory of
everything. Uh, and, uh, everybody,
uh, is supposed to be a string theorist
in theoretical physics at the moment,
except for a few people who point out
that it hasn't actually been all that
successful in explaining
anything. In fact, it hasn't
explained anything ever. Uh,
and therefore might one not want
to consider alternative theories.
And then the strength theorists say, but
you know, ah, this is a really good idea.
We got to continue to look at it one day.
We'll get it right and we'll
figure out everything. Uh, and, uh,
so there has now recently been some
popular books that claimed that string the
string theories theorists are oppressing
everybody else by not letting, uh,
other kinds of good ideas
be funded. Uh, and, uh, uh,
by,
uh,
not letting smart young people who are
working on other things by not hiring
them into departments and so forth. It's
an interesting argument, uh, and, uh,
uh, ongoing in the strength theory
community and some sort of, as I said,
they've been writing popular
books on both sides of this.
So it's kind of busted out into,
you can read about this now and the New
York review of books and places like
that. Uh, and, uh,
so what you do about minority ideas,
ideas that are not supported by,
uh,
the current paradigm of a
given scientific subject is a,
is a very tricky one in
a very interesting one.
And one that needs to be reevaluated
from time to time. And in fact, uh,
cosmology may be approaching such a
moment where a genuinely new idea is going
to have to be required. Uh, we,
we're probably not quite there yet,
but we'll talk about, uh, uh,
alternative cosmological theories toward,
toward the end of the course.
I'm sorry,
I didn't mean to go off on
this, but, but, uh, uh, uh,
it's on my mind cause I had, as I
said, I serve on these committees.
So you have to think about these things.
Actually,
the space telescope people
did a very interesting thing.
At one point they decided,
uh,
I don't think they ever actually
followed through on this,
that 5% or some small amount of
the time, different scientific, uh,
uh,
resources sometimes have this,
that like 5% of the time goes
for risky science. Science.
That's really weird. Probably
won't work. But if it works,
it's incredibly important because,
uh,
committees tend not to want to do that.
Uh,
they tend to want to do the things that
they know are going to produce some good
results. And so sometimes, uh,
the people who organize these
things force the committees, uh,
to have a little category of
special weird project. Uh,
and then of course, what
happened five years later,
they are net and they analyze,
you know, where did all the
good science come from? Uh,
and if it didn't come
from the weird projects,
which is almost certainly the case, uh,
although not 100%, certainly the case,
but generally the case, then they
say, look, we wasted 5% of our money,
telescope time, whatever it is, we're
going to close down this program.
And then you kind of have to start over
again. Uh, so how weird. It is weird, uh,
uh, difficult to say. All right.
The expansion of the
universe. We now believe, uh,
for the reasons I outlined that this
indicates a kind of big bang idea,
which means we can
extrapolate back to the,
that it all started and we can
calculate how long it took. Uh,
let me do a simpler calculation.
Uh, but exactly analogous.
Supposing you're in a car,
you're in a car and you're driving at a
speed of 50 miles per hour and you are
100 miles.
Oh,
away from your starting point,
how long have you been driving?
So this they taught you how to solve
in seventh grade. Uh, if you are,
uh, a hundred miles away, yeah, you,
you take time is equal to
distance over velocity.
Uh, so hundred miles, you're
going 50 miles an hour.
Uh, that means you must have
been going for two hours,
not such a hard problem. Uh,
there's a hidden assumption though.
Sorry. Speed. It's
constant. Yeah. Providing,
provided that the speed is constant.
Okay.
But let's make that assumption.
Let's assume that the universe is
expanding at the same rate all the time.
How, uh, how long has it been going?
Well, take some galaxy, any galaxy,
it turns out it doesn't matter
which galaxy and say, uh, so galaxy,
uh,
a is at distance D it's moving
half Velocity v away from us,
you know, that's the whole idea. Uh,
so how long has it been since
it was right on top of us? Well,
so it's been going for a time equal
to d over v by exact analogy with the
distance,
uh,
velocity time questions that
they ask you about, you know,
cars driving to Cleveland and stuff.
Uh,
so it's been going for type t equals d
over t. But now in the case of galaxies,
there's this interesting relationship
that V is equal to h over d.
So d over V is equal to one over h.
Okay. And that can be measured.
That's Hubble's constant.
And so can you, age of the universe is
equal to one over the Hubble constant
provided that the expansion
has been at a constant rate.
Uh, let me remind you,
H is, is uh, has been,
it's 70 kilometers per
second per mega parsec.
That's kind of an interesting unit. Uh,
you've got kilometers per mega parsec.
Both of those are measures of distance.
Uh,
this is basically velocity over distance,
uh,
and uh, but velocity contains
a distance within it.
So if you were to cancel those two
distance terms in some way, uh,
you'd have that the units of the
Hubble constant are one over seconds.
So the units of one over
the Hubble constant,
our seconds it's and measure of
time. Uh, it's, it's reciprocal time.
One over h is a measure of time. What is
that time? It's the age of the universe.
What do I mean by the age of the universe?
That's how long it has been since all
galaxies and all objects in the universe,
all points in the universe were
piled on top of one another.
Yes.
Uh,
let's see.
Yeah.
Did I write it wrong?
Uh,
p equals yeah. Yeah. I wrote p equals HD.
Thank you. Uh, and so now
what am I going to do?
I'm going to divide both sides by H.
I'm going to divide both sides by V
and then okay. Comes out, right? Sorry.
Thank you very much. Uh,
stop me when I do that. Uh,
right, because this is the huddle, mom.
Okay. So how old is the universe? Well,
it's a one over 70 kilometers
per second per mega parsec. Uh,
that actually is not a very
useful unit of time. Uh,
so let's see if we can do better.
Uh,
h is equal to 70 kilometers per second,
per mega parsec.
Now we want to cancel the
kilometers per mega parsec.
So what we want to multiply this by
is the number of mega parsecs in one
kilometer. That's a very
small number, right? It's,
it's some tiny fraction. Cause in Mega
Parsec is huge. Uh, it's uh, you know,
3 million light years. There's nothing
like that. No kilometer, not so huge. Uh,
so let to calculate this term that's
going to be one kilometer is 10 to the
three meters.
Uh,
one Mega Parsec Amiga is 10 to the six.
A Parsec is three times
10 to the 16 meters. Uh,
and so this is equal to one
third times 10 to the minus 22.
10 to the minus 19 is equal to
a three times 10 to the minus
20.
Right?
Uh,
but at 70 of those,
so h is equal to seven times 10 to the
one times three times 10 to the minus 20,
which is equal to 20 times 10 to the
minus 19 or two times 10 to the minus 18,
uh, in of one over
seconds. So one over age,
we now know in seconds is equal to
one over two times 10 to the minus 18
seconds.
That's a half times 10 to the 18
or five times 10 to the 17 seconds.
One year
is equal to three times
10 to the seven seconds.
So the age of the university in the years
is a five times 10 to the 17,
over three times 10 to the seven a,
which is something like a 1.7
times 10 to the 10 or 17 billion
years.
So that's the answer universally
is 17 billion years old. Uh,
it's not quite the answer because
of that assumption, right?
The assumption was that the universe
is expanding at the same rate, uh,
uh, all the time. And that's
not necessarily true. Uh,
and the next thing we're going
to do is ask the question,
what happens if the expansion rate
of the universe changes with time?
It probably does. It
almost certainly does. Uh,
because the universe is filled with
mass. What does mass do? Mass exerts?
Well, Newton would have it. That
mass exerts gravitational force.
It slows down the expansion of the
universe. So what do you expect?
You expect the universe to be
slowing down gradually? Uh,
and this, uh, gives rise to
a couple of possibilities.
And I think I mentioned this briefly in
passing. Now we're going to do it, uh,
more, uh, in more detail. This is
the scale factor of the universe,
uh, which started at
zero. Uh, here's time.
Here's now a w.
Here's whatever the scale factor
of the university is now, uh, and,
uh, uh, what has happened? Here's,
here's, here's what it looks like.
If there's no change.
So this is constant
expansion.
And so,
uh,
it is this amount of time that
turns out to be 17 billion years.
Uh,
but in fact,
it's all a,
it seems likely that the
universe is in fact slowing down.
So what does that look like?
Well,
that means that in the future
it's going to do this. Uh,
it means that in the
past it was doing this,
uh,
because it was, it's presumably been
slowing down since the very beginning.
And that means that the universe is,
uh, started, uh, later than you think,
because it, it started expanding
more quickly than it is now.
And then it's been slowing down.
So, in fact, you might say, uh,
the unit that what we've really shown
is that the universe has to be less than
17 billion years old.
By the way,
this calculation is why it was such bad
news when Hubble got the answer wrong.
Uh,
you will recall from the problem set,
Hubble thought that the Hubble
constant was 500 kilometers per second,
per mega parsec 500 is a bigger
number. It means, uh, it, it, it's,
uh, what, seven times bigger
than we currently believe.
That means that a Hubble's estimate of
the age of the universe was a factor of
seven smaller than, uh,
uh, 17 billion years,
which is about two and
a half billion years.
So Hubble's the implication of huddles
result for the Big Bang in the big bank
context at least, was that the universe
was two and a half billion years old.
That was very bad news
because the geologists had
already figured out that the
earth was 4 billion years old.
Uh,
and it's not good news to have a planet
that's a factor of two older than the
universe.
Uh,
and so this was part of the initial
suspicion of the Big Bang explanation.
Part of the reason people, uh, uh,
tried to develop steady state ideas
was that Hubble's a calculation of the
constant gave you an age of the universe
that was in contradiction to existing,
uh,
geological ages measured on earth.
By now we're up to 17 billion years
and that seems to, uh, uh, that's fine.
The universe of the earth is only
four and a half billion years old,
so there's no conflict there anymore.
There are some star clusters that are
known to be 12 or 13 billion years old,
uh, and they, uh,
cause some trouble for some values of
the Hubble constant until quite recently.
Uh, okay. Um, so, but then this, uh,
this begs a question, namely, uh,
what's going to happen in the future?
Could it be that the expansion
of the universe stops,
turns around and comes back
leading to a big crunch,
another one of these
technical terms, uh, and uh,
uh, how much mass with the
universe have to contain, uh,
for that to be true? So let
me do that calculation. Now.
This is something we know how to do.
This is an escape philosophy. Problems.
The universe, you know, you throw a,
uh, you throw a pan up in the air.
If you throw it slowly, it stops,
turns around and comes back.
If you throw it fast, it goes
away. Or to put it a different way,
if you throw a pen up in
the air at some velocity,
whether it comes back or not,
depends on the gravitational force
of the planet you're standing on,
which in turn depends on the mass
and the density of that planet. Uh,
so if you set your universe into
motion, it's expanding outward. Uh,
depending on the density of
the universe, uh, it can stop,
turn around and fall back, or it can
keep going. So here's the calculation.
Here's any, here's, here's
us or any other observer.
It works no matter where you
do a, then there's some, uh,
there's some galaxy, some
distance d away from us. Uh,
it's moving outward at a rate of,
uh,
some Velocity v where vias
related to d, uh, by this, uh,
uh, uh, equation or mega
parsec. That's right.
Uh, and then, uh, what's
trying to pull it back? Well,
the mass inside of this region
is trying to hold it back.
It's only the massing side of
that region because the mass, uh,
outside of Erie, we talked about
this in the context of planets.
This all cancels out. Uh, and so,
uh, what is the escape philosophy?
So the escape velocity,
you may recall is the square
root of a to g m over d.
That's the escape philosophy of
this object. And let me make sure
I haven't screwed this up. No, that's
right. Uh, and so the question is,
is the greater than V escape?
All right,
so let's evaluate this.
What's an m is equal to, uh,
uh,
the density
times the volume density,
we'll call that, uh,
the given its usual symbol of row and
the volume is four thirds Pi de que.
That's the volume of
this fear of material.
And you'll see why I translated
into density in a minute. Uh,
the velocity is equal to h Times d.
So the question is,
is h times d greater than the square
root of two g over d times the mass row?
Four thirds Pi Dq.
Alright,
let's square both sides. I got
to get rid of this, uh, uh,
uh, this square root sign.
So h squared, d squared, uh,
is h squared d squared greater
than two g row four thirds Pi.
And we've got a deep cube divided by d.
So that's d squared.
Okay?
And here's the key thing.
The Ds cancel the distance cancel.
It doesn't matter which
galaxy and you pick a,
it doesn't matter how
far away that galaxy is,
you get the exact same result for every
portion of the universe you examine.
So the question becomes,
is
the density less than
three eight squared over eight Pi?
Gee, I've just rearranged the terms. Uh,
this is the row.
It's still on the less than side I've
taken the two times four is eight,
that's this eight.
There's a pie that goes down here.
This three comes over on top and the h
nods and the h squared stays where it is.
So this quantity is defined
as the critical Danson.
If the density of the universe is
less than the critical density,
the universe expands forever.
Yeah.
If the density of the universe is
greater than the critical density,
then the universe re collapses.
So, uh, we can calculate this. Uh,
this is all constants
on this right hand side.
We've measured h we've measured h,
so we know what that is.
Three times two times 10 to the minus 18.
That's h a. We work that out square, uh,
over eight Pi Times seven
times 10 to the minus 11.
Uh, and now it's just arithmetic.
And I'll tell you the answer.
We, you can work it out for yourself. Uh,
I got six times 10 to the minus 27,
and this isn't units of
kilograms per meter cube.
That's a really small density.
It doesn't take much to hold the
universe back. On the other hand,
the universe is really big. Uh,
obviously the density of, of,
of this room of the air in
this room is 20. Uh, it,
it is 30 orders of magnitude bigger.
That's why the earth isn't expanding
because we're so dense that our little
region of the universe has turned
around and re collapsed log since.
But if you take the universe as a whole,
planets are rare.
Stars are rare.
Galaxy's even are rare.
And it turns out as well,
discuss next time, uh,
that the universe is actually
fairly close, uh, in, in bulk.
If you take a large enough region
that includes all the empty space,
it turns out that the average density
of the universe is actually surprisingly
close to this critical value at which
the universe will be balanced between
expanding forever and re collapsing.
And so we'll talk about how you actually
measure the average density of the
universe and thus determine the
fate of the universe. Uh, next time.